of course not taking responsibility I
assumed well there's something wrong
with you emotionally clearly it's not me
you're not able to give me what I need
emotionally onward I would go to seek my
next relationship this ideal partner who
would just get me little did I know
until I began to look at the role I was
playing which was actually keeping
myself so emotionally distant from
myself because remember I didn't have
that Attunement in childhood so my
safest space was to distract or to
dissociate why I wasn't feeling
emotionally connected and why many of us
feel alone in a crowded room we're with
partners and we feel a sense of
emptiness still we aren't actually being
ourselves which include our emotions I
was so far away protected in my
spaceship that the reason why I wasn't
able to allow myself to be connected to
and to connect with another person was
because I wasn't connected to
myself